[Music]
hello how are you andrés gonzález greets you
with his brief informative for today Tuesday
March 30 the governor of nevada
styps islands gave the green light to resume
the practice of physical contact sports
leagues clubs and associations
will now be able to practice this and as long
as  implement a safety plan
which includes limits, protocols and
restrictions prior to the activity
coaches and players who are not
active must continue to use the
masks for more information visit the
snow dotcom diagonal in Spanish
and another vaccination center is
now available in henderson  it is
inside the san severiano community center
if you are eligible to vaccinate this site
will offer 800 daily doses
starting today through friday
changing the subject the riders might
get to have another home
game next season
this is it the nfl will vote to add it
a game to the regular season of 16
to 17 games this means that  Las
Vegas' would face the Chicago Bears
as an extra game inside the list stadium
and now we will look at the weather forecast. We
will have temperatures
around 70 degrees, however, despite being
a sunny day, the winds will continue in
the valley until the day of  tomorrow we will see
a rise in temperatures as we approach
the weekend have a nice day
I am andrés gonzález and this was your
brief news now in Spanish
[Music]